a couple of months ago we asked
Americans who they trusted to keep their
personal information private and we
found that more Americans trusted
government agencies like the NSA and the
IRS than private companies like Facebook
and Google however in this poll we took
it a step further instead of just asking
about protecting their personal
information we wanted we wanted to know
who they were most concerned about
violating their personal information and
as it turns out a majority are more
concerned about government agencies like
the IRS and the NSA violating them than
they are private companies like Facebook
and Google and what this tells us is
that Americans make a distinction
between government collection of
personal data and private companies
collecting personal data because they
understand that private companies are
using this information to sell them
things and the government is using this
information to spy on them and they
think the government spying on them is
worse
you